[تصفيق]
ميسالا خذ واحدة وأريد أن أعود بك
إلى مجد دوري أبطال أوروبا وأنت
ترفع هذا الكأس كيف كان الأمر
رائعًا بصراحة ، أنت تعلم أنه حلم لكل
مدينة أن يفوز اللاعب بدوري أبطال
أوروبا أو شيء رائع
ويهرب  يونيو 2019 وانتصار
المصلى وزملائه في ليفربول بتتويجهم
بطلاً لأوروبا
لمجد نادي صلاح تلاه تحول مخيب للآمال
في الأحداث مع المنتخب المصري
في كأس الأمم الأفريقية هذا العام
قبل أشهر فقط من
انطلاق البطولة.  على
الاستضافة ولكن ميزة العشب الداخلي لم
تساعد الفراعنة الذين فشلوا في أدوار
خروج المغلوب ولم يؤدوا في
المستوى الأعلى بأمانة ، لذلك أنا لا
أتحدث فقط أنا لا أتحدث
عن اللاعب وأتحدث  أنا نفسي
لكننا كفريق لم نقدم أداءً جيدًا ولكن
كان هناك الكثير من الضغط على اللاعب في
المنتخب الوطني ، لم يكونوا
سعداء بالكثير من الأشياء.
في التجربة ،
هل يحتاجون إلى إصلاح شامل ، كما
تعتقد في زميل كرة القدم المصري
، أعني أنك خضت عددًا
من المنافسات مع الاتحاد ، نعم
لدي الكثير أعتقد أنه كان من الضروري فقط أن
نكون صادقين مع أنفسنا في بعض الأحيان  بالنسبة
للمنتخب الوطني
، فإن الاتحاد ألق نظرة على
الحسابات معي ، فأنت تعلم أن
موقعي مختلف قليلاً عن
اللاعبين ، لذا ليس لأنني نجم ولكن
أيضًا لأنه يجعلني أشعر بالراحة
على سبيل المثال دولة أفريقية كان لدينا
كانوا في الفندق وكان الناس يأتون
إلى الفندق بسهولة ،
فهم يجلسون في الطابق السفلي بسهولة ، وهو أمر
غير طبيعي كان لدينا يوم عطلة ولم
أستطع النزول من الغرفة حتى
9:00 9:30 عندما حاولت النزول  كان
كل شيء
مثل 200 شخص معي وأنا أقول
لماذا تشكو أنا أشتكي
لأنني في أي وقت مضى أنا إنسان أريد أن أكون
مع اللاعبين ، هل
فكرت يومًا في الاعتزال من المنتخب الوطني
، من الصعب جدًا أن تعلم أنني أحب
هذا  بلد من قلبي "  كان دائمًا
في ذهني عندما غادرت مصر ، لذلك عندما
كان عمري 19 عامًا ، كان دائمًا في
ذهني شيئًا يدفعني إلى الأمام
للأداء ، أصبح التبول
مبدعًا للأطفال ليكونوا مثل
الحلم للأطفال ليكونوا في يوم من الأيام مثلي  في
رأيي ، أريد أن أكون ذلك الشخص ، لذا فإن
اعتزال المنتخب الوطني
أمر ضخم بالنسبة لي ،
فقد طغى الجدل على الأداء الباهت على أرض
الملعب بسبب الجدل الذي نشب في وقت مبكر
من البطولة ، حيث أطلق الاتحاد المصري لكرة القدم
أماورا المياه على الفريق
.  بعد ظهور
ادعاءات بالتحرش الجنسي
على الإنترنت ، لكن أعيد اللاعب البالغ من العمر 25 عامًا
إلى منصبه بعد أن بدا أن اللاعبين الرئيسيين بما في ذلك
صلاح يقدمون له الدعم على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ، فلنتحدث عن
الجدل حول الماء في هذا الصيف ،
هل ساعده
تدخلك على العودة إلى الفريق بعد أن كان
تم الإيقاف في البداية بسبب مزاعم
التحرش الجنسي ليس على الإطلاق
لأنني لست قائد المنتخب الوطني
أنا لست مدير الفريق لست المدرب
صدقني  أنا قوي ، كان بإمكاني
تغيير الكثير من الأشياء هناك ، لكنني
لاعب ولكن هذا لا يدعمني ، هل
يمكننا إلقاء نظرة على التغريدة وتذكير
مشاهدينا بما قلته أنه يجب
معاملة النساء بأقصى درجات الاحترام ، لا أنت
قال يعني أنه لا توجد هذه الأشياء ويجب أن
تظل مقدسة ، لقد ذهبت إلى الوضع لتقول إنني
أعتقد أيضًا أن العديد من الذين يرتكبون أخطاء
يمكن أن يتغيروا للأفضل ولا
يجب إرسالهم مباشرة إلى المقصلة
وهي أسهل طريقة للخروج يجب أن
نؤمن بها  الفرص الثانية التي نحتاجها
لتوجيه وتثقيف الابتعاد عن
الإجابة ، دعنا نذكر أنفسنا بأن هذه
لم تكن المرة الأولى التي اتُهم فيها زمرد
وادا بالتحرش الجنسي ،
ماذا تقول للأشخاص الذين ينتقدون
تلك التغريدة التي نشرتها ويقولون إنك
تؤيدها  سلوكه ما قصدت قوله
هو أنه حدث قبل أن يحدث التعيس
الآن ، لذا فإن التحرش الجنسي ، نعم ،
إنه شخص يجب عليه الحصول على علاج
أو إعادة تأهيل ، لذا لا يقتصر الأمر على
التأكد من أنه لن يحدث
مرة أخرى ،
لذا دعني أكون هادئًا  واضح أنا ماء
وآخرون مذنبون بارتكاب التحرش الجنسي ،
فأنت تستخدم المصطلح بحاجة إلى إعادة التأهيل ، نعم ،
ما أعنيه ليس شخصًا
معينًا ولكن بشكل عام ، نعم
، يحتاجون إلى التأهيل والعلاج
لذلك ، لذا تأكد فقط من أنه ليس كذلك
سيحدث مرة أخرى ، لقد تم
اتهامك بالنفاق عندما تم التصويت
لك واحدًا من أكثر 100 مرة ،
تحدثت عن الحاجة إلى تغيير
المواقف تجاه النساء في الشرق
الأوسط ثم تغريدة ، لذا اشرح فقط
ما هو موقفك بالنسبة لي إذا كنت
ألن يكون موقفي ستيلا كما أخبرتك أن
هناك أشخاصًا يسيئون فهم ما
أقوله ولكن في هذه الأثناء ، ما
أتحدث عنه إذا كان على المرأة أن تحصل
عليها في الشرق الأوسط ، يمكنك
القول إن لم يكن  أشهر
عارف في العالم اليوم كيف تستخدم
هذه المنصة للترويج للتغيير أولاً وقبل
كل شيء علينا أن نقبل أن هناك
مشكلة وأنا أعلم أنه من الصعب
جدًا قبول ذلك ولكن المشكلة عميقة بنسبة 100٪
والشيء الثاني في رأيي هو المرأة التي
لها الحق في التحدث عن أي شيء
لا تحبه ، فأنا أتحدث عن
نفسي وأريده عندما
تواجه ابنتي مشكلة ، يجب أن تشعر بالدعم
لي في المستقبل  للتحدث معي عن
المشكلة أهم شيء هو
الخوف الذي تخافه الزوجة
من زوجها من والدها ،
وهذه هي النقطة الأساسية التي أعتقد
أن الخوف ليس صحيًا لأي شخص ، لذلك
علينا أن نصلح ذلك
مامي شخصيًا هل تغيرت.
مواقفك تجاه المرأة مع
تقدمك في التطور ابتعدت عن مصر
وأصبحت ناجحة في أوروبا أعتقد نعم
لقد تغيرت كثيرًا من الشخص
الذي أتحدث عنه مثل
الحجم الذي تخيفه الأسرة منه ومن
الزوجة أو الابنة أو  كل ما
يتحدث إليه الشخص الآن كما لو كان
يقاتل من أجله مرة أخرى هو الموضوع
لأنه يرى أنها
مخطئة بالطبع قبل أن لا أنجب
ابنتي لأنني كنت أعتقد أن القطع
المكافئة بدأت في التغيير مثل تسع سنوات مضت عشر
سنوات  قبل ars كنت تعرف أي شيء ولكن هذا
الشخص الآن يقاتل مرة أخرى هو
الموضوع لأنني أستطيع أن أرى أنه من الخطأ جدًا
ما هو رأيك في أنا جيد
ولكن هذا هو جوابي دائمًا لماذا
أحب كرة القدم أوه كيف هي
حسنًا ، في بعض الأحيان ، يكون هذا الأمر يحمي اللاعبين
من اللعب الخطير ، لكن بالنسبة لي
قبلت كرة القدم
بأخطاء لاعب كرة القدم المشار إليه ، فهذه هي
الطريقة التي سيصبح بها الطعام أكثر حماسًا لدرجة
أن الناس بطريقة ما يصبحون أكثر صبراً
بشأن ذلك ولكن الواقع الافتراضي كان عادلاً للغاية
العام الماضي  لقد تلقيت ركلة جزاء في نهائي
دوري أبطال أوروبا وقد ساعدتني كثيرًا ،
لكن من العدل جدًا أننا نحبها مع
الأخطاء ، من المثير للاهتمام أن تقول عادلًا جدًا ،
نعم تعتقد أن اللعبة تحتاج إلى
القليل من التفوق بالطبع
وهذا ما يحبه الجميع  كرة القدم
، أريد أن أعطيك مثالًا جيدًا
ربما لماذا قد يعجبك var في
استطلاع حديث ، قال مشجعو كرة القدم إن
شركات فينسنت تتعامل ضدك
في الموسم الماضي ، والتي من أجلها حصل فقط
على بطاقة صفراء قال الرجل إنه  ذهبوا للفوز
على ليفربول كانت الحلقة
التي أرادوا مراجعتها من قبل فار ، فأنت تقول إنك
لا تحب الإصدار 8 ، أعني أنك فقط
لحماية اللاعبين ، السبب الوحيد الذي جعلني أستقيل
لم أستطع فعلاً ، فما
رأيك في التأثير؟  من var ستكون
في اللعبة ، بالنسبة لي ، المزيد من العقوبات بالنسبة لي
، سترى ما
قد يساعدك على الفوز بالكلب مرة أخرى
، لقد أرادته بالطبع ، لكن بالنسبة لي
، يأتي كأس الفريق
أولاً ، يأتي كأس الفريق أولاً ، وخاصة
الدوري الإنجليزي الممتاز.  إذا حصلت
على الهزيمة الثالثة على التوالي ، فلا بأس
أن أحصل على المركز الثالث ، وربما في
العام المقبل لا بأس بذلك ، وقد
سجل فيرمينو مجموع 113 هدفًا في
الموسمين الأخيرين ، ما أهمية أن هذا الثلاثي
لليفربول هو عمل جماعي ، لذا نعم  ربما
سجلنا أكبر عدد من الأهداف مع
ليفربول ولكن لا يمكنني أخذ
ذلك من اللاعبين الآخرين
لأنهم يعملون بجد حقًا
ويدافعون كثيرًا ويعطوننا كل كرة
ونحاول دائمًا أن نجعل الفارق
أهم شيء  يشبه k  الفوز في eep استمر في الفوز واستمر في
الفوز
وسيأتي الخير ، هل تشعر وكأنك
آلة تسجيل ذهبية فقط من باب
الاهتمام لا لأنني لست مهاجمًا
ألعب كجناح ، لذا فإن وظيفتي المناسبة وليس
مجرد هداف يجب أن يقدم أيضًا تمريرات حاسمة
ألعب مع خط الوسط ، لذا ، نعم ، ألعب
كجناح لم يوصيه أحد لفترة
طويلة وأنت مرتاح
هناك حيث تريد أن تكون ، نعم ، أنا
مرتاح ، لكنني أعني ولكن نظرًا
لأنها ليست وظيفتي الأولى مثل الرقم.
تسعة مهمته فقط للتسجيل أو السماح
بدعوته ، ولكن كجناح ليس فقط للتسجيل ،
إنه تقديم المساعدة واللعب
باللعب مع الفريق ، فأنا أفعل الكثير من
الأشياء للدفاع عن مثل هذه الوظيفة وهذا
يجعلك أفضل  كرة القدم يمكن أن أقول
لك إن صديقك
رقم تسعة لا ولكن من الواضح أن
بوبي المصنف تسعة هو على حق ، إنه أحد
أفضل اللاعبين الذين لعبت معهم على الإطلاق ، لقد كان
موسمًا رائعًا العام الماضي ،
تفوق مانشستر سيتي على ليفربول في كل من
الاستحواذ والتسجيل.  كما
كان قليلا  سجل أفضل
لتحريك الكرة من الثلث الأوسط إلى
الثلث الأخير بالتفكير في هذا الموسم
ليأتي ما هو مفتاح ذلك
أعتقد أنه فرق في
بعض الأحيان يعتمد على اللعبة
أحيانًا لديك خبرة الآن
للفوز بالمباراة مرة واحدة  وهذا
يكفي أعتقد أننا فعلنا ذلك مثل
العام الماضي سبع أو ثماني مرات ، لذا
لا يهم كيفية الاحتفاظ بالكرة أو
مقدار احتفاظك بالكرة ، يتعلق الأمر فقط
بكيفية الفوز بالمباراة التي لعبتها
لمدة 11 شهرًا في  يتجادل مع عدم وجود ما
قبل الموسم عمليًا وتدريب قليل جدًا ، آه ،
يُطلب من كرة القدم أن تفعل الكثير من نظام
MacOS ، وهذا ما يجعل كرة القدم
متحمسة جدًا لأن الناس يحبون كرة القدم
الشخص وكل شيء لذلك أنا سعيد
بلعب كل مباراة ولا أريد حتى الراحة
مباراة واحدة ، لذلك أنا سعيد باللعب لفترة طويلة ،
هناك توقعات كبيرة على
لاعبي كرة القدم في مستواك ، هل هذه
التوقعات مرتفعة جدًا في بعض الأحيان أو هل
تشعر أنها مناسبة تمامًا إذا كنت
تلعب بالنادي كما لو كان ليفربول
موجودًا دائمًا  كبير  توقع
أن تفوز بشيء ما ، لذلك هناك
دائمًا توقعات عالية في كرة القدم
إذا لم تكن من أنفسكم من
الناس لأنهم يريدون أن يروا النادي
يفوز بشيء ما ، ما هي الرسالة
في بداية الموسم لك كثيرًا
من الصراخ استمر في العمل  بجد ،
وإذا كنت ترغب في الفوز بشيء آخر ،
فعليك أن تعمل بجد أكثر مما لم يحدث
في الموسم الماضي ، وعليك أن تكون
متواضعًا حقًا وبصحة جيدة ، لقد انتهى نيك تامبا ، لقد
انتهى العام الماضي ، لذا انسى أنه
قاتل من أجل الكؤوس الجديدة مرة أخرى هذا
الموسم 97  نقطة وأنت تخجل نقطة
من الفوز بالدوري ، هذا
صعب أليس كذلك هل أشعر أن الطريق طويل
أمامنا في بداية هذا
الموسم أعتقد أنني أعتقد ذلك ، لكنك تعلم
أننا نلعب ضد مان سيتي نحن نعلم أننا
أعتقد أن كلا الفريقين في نفس المستوى في
الوقت الحالي ، لذلك نحتاج فقط إلى التركيز على
لعبتنا وليس لعبتهم بقدر ما يمكنك
الفوز في كل مباراة ، سيكون الأمر على
ما يرام مثل الموسم الماضي أعتقد أنه
خسرنا مباراة واحدة فقط  الجا واحد  لي لذا
علينا أن نركز هذا الموسم على
أنفسنا حتى لا نخسر مرة أخرى